it's a fling keV calm exclusive I want
to talk to you um I saw that
Method Man had kind of called out
McLemore for four crowd walking I don't
know if you saw man I know that you've
been like real heavy and I'll do the
growl walking jumping off into the crowd
I mean um I mean I know that you've kind
of expressed your I don't want to say
anger but I mean you know we the first
time I individual Vegas you kind of
express some sort of you know thanks to
the fact that you were doing that before
a lot of rappers are doing it yeah I
feeI and I think it's one of those
things was like I carried on the
tradition for this generation random
method man's you know I'm saying it
wasn't right so I mean you know petty
stuff like that is something I wouldn't
like focus on but I mean it's definitely
like you know when you're out there
doing it on award shows like millions of
people and you know you're getting that
you know Jesus here you're getting the
things that somebody else like right
nothing is like you know like when week
every rapper see me perform pretty much
yeah then every rapper see me perform on
on some real stuff adoption I'm sure a
lot of lot of them internally whether
it's rest of or yeah I got that that's
what I'm saying all the festivals from
all the showcases we call ourselves well
that's like we've all seen each other
for Frank you know Ty and we know
exactly what Machine Gun Kelly does on
stage don't sit there in front like the
turn up in your set was not inspired by
Machine Gun Kelly you can't learn that
the energy all that stuff that that was
that was I was inspired by what was
going on stage years ago and I Machine
Gun Kelly show it just so happens that
my crowds are a little lighter than
theirs you know I'm saying so what's
your take of this new freshman class
that came out of course you're an alumni
from the freshman class I mean I thought
there were some hits I thought there
were some this is you know I mean what's
your take on the double XL freshman
class
I'm nothing I'm just out the loop you
don't need me pay attention a pop like
that's even it is there someone who you
thought should have made made the cover
that didn't make the cover at this point
and it's so it's so based off politics
and that stripe and stuff it's like why
even comment actually but uh you know
that that would mean I can really
comment I was that that we're talk about
a magazine who pulled an article of mine
they did and you know saying and in the
last issue of the magazine with a set up
in front of the cover Oh what happened
with that you know I don't know dog they
were scared of us man he's worse he was
getting is crazy because you would be so
smart it would be so smart any cover up
then on like really it's just time
released are just bringing our black and
whites you know I'm saying of the facts
of things and this is not as setting um
this is not setting angry tone either
because right I'm very for pastor I'm on
a headline to that I'm selling do
everything it's like you're in a better
place exactly so it's not like this is
not like you know it's not like I I'm
like in a point where I'm like you know
I'm down at the bottom and I'm
complaining is not that is you shady
back so I feel like people should like I
feel like it should come to light
because I feel like people should feel
some type of way about like I do um but
you know on the cuff you put any kind of
cover of a magazine history shows that
every time on the cover of whatever
magazine it was Inked Magazine was the
fastest selling copy that you know I'm
saying you come back put me on the cover
of these other magazines they're the
most they're the most ordered there's
literally I won't even name this
magazine but there's a magazine who
literally gets their paycheck off of my
fans ordering that magazine that's crazy
you know I'm saying like their page like
I know no one else is checking I'm
saying like and it's like one of those
things where it's like I know this cuz
I'm Mitchell person all you can talk
about is how crazy like it is that
people and Poland are putting in like an
order for this magneto saying like yeah
um then you know for me to spend three
four hours in the cold for a photoshoot
for you
neither's have so many good
relationships inside that building do so
many things from just you know freestyle
all these things they just know just
giving your soul too you know thing and
it's to have a heart and will put you to
yeah to have a particle pool and I'm
talking like a good like you know three
six or eight or yeah you don't it's like
it was like a it's like damn we spent a
long time on this I gave you everything
just for it you never come out first
never come out and then and it's like
dude you're playing with my life then
that's real you know I'm saying like
you're playing with my life doll just
because you like in this ridiculous why
would you not want to hear from from
from what we got going on but that's
real you know so that so I mean as far
as though even the devil issue goes dude
props everybody on that thing but that
just depth that magazine with with what
they with what them and along with the
other yeah I mean I feel like you're
like one of those you know one of the I
mean I feel like every year double
except for the most part they get I mean
sixty seventy percent of the cover right
that you know they like go out and have
a good year you've done your thing you
drop the album you like you say you're
torn um so you know I just wanted to get
your take on that but you know